hello
everyone I hope everyone is enjoying
fire data and I had the lunch how was
it it was good okay so getting back so I
an and I will be your host for the event
and today we
have um he he has been a part of P data
for over 15 years now and he's also the
CEO CTO sorry C of goite and today in
this event we'll be talking about we'll
be going like more on how to develop an
AI assistant with our AZ so if you are a
new beginner or experienced professional
you're going to have a lot of fun in
this event you're going to learn a lot
of things and take a lot of things in a
back for sure all you sir thank you hey
folks um my name is dtina I'm from it
and I'm going to do something a little
dangerous I'm going to try and run
things live um and we'll see how that
goes um I'll be using uh open API open
ai's um API and last night and this
morning it's been really flaky and I
heard there was some kind of cloud flare
thing that happened yesterday and I
don't know if that's got anything to do
with it so we'll see but I have a
pre-run version as well in case things
go really bad um a little bit about
quanite quanite is a consulting company
focused on the P dat ecosystem we have a
lot of the core developers of packages
you know and love like P toor SciFi and
numi lot of them work onite um we do a
lot of Consulting with clients and then
usually when we learn things we say oh
there's an opportunity for a new open
source package here and today I'm going
to be talking about uh a new open source
package we released this week called
ragna and also using it in conjunction
with another really cool package called
panel and I'm going to do a couple of
things one is I'm going to to walk you
through building your own little AI
assistant uh but at the same time
um if you go to that link rna. quanite
dodev and put a email address or name uh
and just put the password as FNA um you
if if it doesn't log you in just hit log
in again and it should we just stood
this up this morning uh this is a fully
featured application that lets you
upload a PDF or a couple of PDFs choose
different models choose different Vector
databases ask questions and you know see
how it works and to give you a little
flavor of this um why do we want to do
this so this is this is here I uploaded
um three PDFs uh these are like annual
reports from Tesla GM and um uh Ford and
I asked a couple of questions you know
how much money did they make you know
did Ford earn more than GM yeah nice
questions you can ask about a PDF
actually chat gbt announced yesterday if
you're in the beta and have chat GB plus
they have an ability to do this but a
lot of the commercial companies are
complete blackbox here if you if I click
on this info is my mic going in and out
yes should I do something about the mic
anyone
here open put it further
up hello okay we'll see um you see in
this case I used anthropic and uh
anthropic quad and I think I used chroma
as a um Vector database I'm going to
talk about what a vector database is and
what llms are in a little bit uh but
also if you look here I can look at the
source info where did this information
come from and if you look this
information came from these pages in the
Tesla PDF these pages in the GM PDF and
these pages in The you know other PDFs
that's where this information came from
looks pretty
reasonable did Ford earn more than GM
you know it looks like it it it got some
good information you know 2021 all this
kind of stuff but then look at the
source
info okay looks good now let's look at a
different model we're using CLA and
we're going to use a different Vector
database for Lance DB and here you know
I've asked the same questions I've got
some answers but if I look at the source
info it's only looked at the Ford
PDF so it made this really nice answer
answer
saying but but it only looked at one PDF
and that's one of the reason why we
built this tool because over the last
year actually let me roll back a second
who works in an organization any kind of
organization how many of your
organizations are really going crazy
like how do I use AI how do I use CHP
how do I use it in my organization how
do I use it right now okay so that's
where we've come in and we have a couple
this is really going in and out maybe
I'll just hold it
hello okay
um we've had several clients who are all
have at a high level this question how
do I use AI what is it useful for yes I
can make a really cool image of a cat in
space but how does that help me with my
organization or my company and we've
been helping them experiment you know uh
basically essentially it's gone like
this the CTO or CEO reads A blog post
and then they say hey can we do this and
we were like well yeah it was a blog
post we actually tried it and it doesn't
work and so we went through this
procedure of trying different things and
finding out they don't work and we're
like this is really annoying to try
these things and find out they don't
work let's let's make a framework make
easier so let's talk a little bit about
retrieval argumented
Generation Um one of the big things that
came up of the use case of multiple
clients is this idea that we have all
these internal documents we want to ask
reading them we have 40 Years of
documents no analyst can read all those
documents and summarize them and
understand them wouldn't it be great if
we could use uh chat gbt or llms to just
ask a question you know which which was
the best business strategy and it would
magically give us the
answer great idea very difficult to do
in practice um for those you don't know
llms like can I change mics do we have a
handheld or something oh
yeah
um llms like CH GPT or Claude or llama
these are built on extremely large but
static data
sets it's going in an out at least I can
feel it going in an out you guys hear it
going in and out yeah does this work
better okay um so I you know this is an
ragna's an open source framework that we
actually open sourced 3 days ago and I
asked CH GPT what is ragna
framework it has no idea because it was
trained on a data set that ended in
January
2022 okay I asked Google Google kind of
crawls the web all the time you know
they're not using I mean yes I'm
starting to use AI but you know Google
has fresh data we put this website up 3
days ago and Google knows what ragna
framework is llms inherently are trained
on Ax data set when you want to ask
questions about your internal documents
or something new you have to find some
way to provide that new data over to the
um the
all the simplest way cut and paste all
that data and stick it in with your
prompt so you're writing a prompt you
know uh how much did Ford make this year
and then you paste all the text from the
PDF in your prompt and say you please
use only this new data I've given
you okay that works you can do it for a
small case but most of these llms have
something called a context window or
like you know it's got a couple of
different names but with chat GPD 3.5
you can enter in about 3,000 words with
chat
gbd4 I think it's bigger and then Claude
and anthropic some of the proprietary
ones they're saying you can add to
70,000 tokens which map the words in a
particular
way how many documents do you think you
can get in with 3,000
words not very many uh it's usually
that's that's basically a page so the
one of the there's there's two ways to
give new information to an one is what's
called called fine tuning and fine
tuning is where you retrain the model
and you you adjust all of its parameters
on a new data set that's pretty
expensive uh you have to use gpus you
have to you know do a lot of stuff and
it takes a while but the other approach
is what is called retrieval retrieval
augmented generation and essentially
what we do we take our you know we take
our
documents we tokenize them we break them
into little pieces and then we do
something called a vector embedding we
use a vector embedding model and it
takes all those little pieces and it
puts it into a vector space so things
that are similar are uh get Associated
together like you know man and woman
probably in Vector space are close
together and then so but it's not words
tokens are actually fractions of words
and you know there are multiple
algorithms on how to tokenize and how to
embed then you put it into a vector
store and a vector store or a vector
database is just a dat database that's
optimized for storing vectors and R
retrieving them quickly and so you know
we got all our data we got our like 10
PDFs we've put it we've tokenized it
we've embedded it we've put it in a
vector database now I asked a question
how much did Ford make last year it
takes that
question and it does the same
tokenization and the same Vector
embedding for my query it is going to do
a similarity match between my Vector
with my query and the entire Vector
database and there's like multiple
algorithms on how to do this I think the
you know and everyone's competing on the
best new algorithm to do these
similarity searches now I'm going to do
this similarity search between my query
and all the documents in the all the all
the document fractions in the vector
database and I'm going to get a list of
text Snippets so let's say I had you
know 10 PDFs each were like 200 pages
long it is going the similarity search
is going to give me an ordered list from
a nearest neighbor or something of text
chunks that are most likely to have the
answer and now I take those text chunks
and I instead of trying to feed the
entire set of 10 PDFs into my llm I'm
just taking those few text chunks along
with a prompt saying hey please answer
my question with this text I'm supplying
and I send that to the um lolm
okay do you see how many components
there are in here there's a vector
database there's an embedding model
there's a tokenization model there is a
similarity search and then there are
generative
llms that's a lot of
variables and you can tweak each one of
those and get different answers and for
different types of text or different
types of data like um one of the things
I didn't show you over here is if I do
new chat let me do a new
chat here um you know once I choose let
me say pb4 and last DB here we can
choose different chunk sizes you how how
big is each text Chunk and but again if
you break something into chunks maybe
you have a sentence which goes between
chunks so how much chunk overlap do you
want to have between different chunks
when you when you're breaking it up and
then there's model configuration so
there's all these different
configuration
options
and what works what doesn't work what
we're presenting is a tool for you to
explore what works and what doesn't work
on your own instead of having to rely
on you know chat GPT over open AI or
anthropic or mosaic or any of these
companies they those companies will let
you upload a PDF and they will let you
ask
questions but you don't know how they're
generating the answer I you know in some
of the examples we might see today we
might not because generative AI is not
um deterministic sometimes you will get
an answer because I've done this i' I've
got I've written a question and I've got
an answer and then I look at the sources
and I ask the question about GM and all
the sources say Ford and I'm like huh
I'm pretty sure this is wrong or it's
just made up
because the text you're using isn't will
definitely not have the answer so this
is also a way to verify
hallucinations okay today we're going to
talk about and I'm going to go through
some code really quickly and we're going
to be using ragna which is the new uh
framework for building generative apps
and we're going to use panel which is a
tool for building web applications
really quickly with low code um and so
I'm going to use a couple of documents
so here I have three I
have um three documents ones are four
one's about GM and one is just a little
text file of what is ragna and it just
has a list there ragna is a python
framework that lets you quickly build
rag apps but also provides a qbas back
end and AR rest API so if you want to
build a front end on top of it you can
quickly go from research to actually
deploying something in your organization
without having throw everything away and
rewrite it which we had to do before we
have this
um we can set it up we you know you
install it we need keys to various
Services um and you do a ragna in it it
kind of sets up all the pieces that you
need to do one of the things I found out
yesterday uh so since we work with lots
of clients we have API keys to some of
these Commercial Services like Mosaic ML
and anthropic clae and all this uh this
week I was trying to make instructions
of how you guys should get all these
keys and I realized that unless you're a
big organization you
can't uh open AI you can get keys uh but
anthropic basically says if you're if
you've got money talk to them and mic
basically says they have high demand and
stay tuned so you know so this gu to the
other part these are the services these
are API services and you want to try out
the API Services see how well they do
but you also want to use there's plenty
of Open Source LMS out there there's all
these llama 2 variants there's you know
all these different things and so ragna
has a plug-in architecture so you know
we we we here I got a little bit of code
I'm not going to go through it just a
little bit that just takes this model
called aerob borus it's the smallest
model I can find on hugging face and
wraps it into a little
plugin and then here now I have I'm
importing you know open AI G gbd4 and
GPD 3.5 and I'm also importing my local
llm and this local llm will run on my
GPU and the little graphs going past of
my of my uh GPU over there um set up the
model and I'm I'm going to set up two
chats here I'm setting up one
chat oh actually this is a mistake
that's why it wasn't working
earlier I was making it go faster not
doing this okay so I'm going to look at
all the
documents and if you look at this this
is going to take a couple of minutes to
what's called embed so this is going to
take a few minutes I'm going to talk
What's happen this is doing the
tokenization and putting everything into
the vector database chroma and Lance DB
are vector databases that you can run
kind of in memory a lot of the other
ones like PG Vector
we8 um pine cone uh those you kind of
have to set up a separate server so for
the examples we haven't done that
um and this actually I was hoping to re
pre-run this but I didn't
so we'll see if not I'm going to switch
over to my pre-run and we'll come back
to this
um okay so once you've prepared the
models this one
finish still
going
okay I'm going to switch
here on once you've prepared the models
youve kind of got them set up the data
the documents we being embedded then you
can ask questions and like here I've
asked a question to um my local llm and
I've got an answer and it looks like it
just spit back the text 12 back to me
and then I got the same thing using open
AIS 3.5 and it's done a little
summarization um and if we look at the
sources answer. sources the sources use
the text Chunk is this text Chunk which
looks like my little text file indicator
so yes it's working uh in the
experiments I did leading up to this
talk often I got crazy stuff there when
I changed some settings you know um and
we also found a bug in chroma that we
found but anyway
um so let me see if this is no it's
still going okay I was hoping to show
you
oh oh yeah it is using the GPU right now
okay so it if you see the GPU line went
up because it's pegging the GPU trying
to run the model right now but anyway I
will go back to my pre-run
version now we're going to do this we're
going to now convert this so that was
nice you know I got jup cells I'm asking
questions a little clunky but actually I
would like to actually make a little
chat widget okay and so for this we're
going to use panel um and panel has a
really nice um chat interface
widget which you can use to make
different types of chat very easily and
so we're going to use
that and we're going to basically Define
a little call back function and all this
is going to do is take your question
your query and your username actually
and um answer that that same you know
I've got my chat DVD answer here and my
chat local answer
here let me see if this one finished
oops
yes it's finished we can do this live
okay well actually live unless the oh
see there you see the GPU go up and down
and
then obviously something
broke yeah it's demo so okay that's why
I have a pre-run version this all worked
20 minutes ago
um so Okay so we've got this so we got
this um you know we've got this little
call back function and then I'm going to
set up my chat widget and in my chat
widget I'm just doing I'm saying use
that call back function whenever a
question is asked I'm going to give it
some nice things I'm going to call the
I'm going to call it ragna I'm going to
say this is the user is me I'm going to
use my little image and and there's a
couple of buttons I don't want so I kind
of hit fine okay and now I'm going to
start it up and I'm going to start it up
with a message saying get a reply for R
now okay and so now I have a chat widget
and you know this could be put in a
website or whatever but now let's let's
ask a question let's
see oh
my let's see what should we say
did or
earn
more
than
GM okay so it should
chug and hopefully you should see the Y
you know should see the GPU go up so
it's going to do two things one of the
questions is going to go to open ai's
API and come back one of the questions
is going to go to the GPU and come back
so there's a little Spike on the GPU for
the local llm and the other
one okay okay they basically say they
you know or the local one says for's
more than GM but gbt saying no I don't
know okay
um how
much did
Bo and so one of the things you have to
realize here
is these models don't have any
intelligence and this is doing a
similarity search to find text chunks
in the vector database so if I say which
company made
more it's not going to know what to
match in the vector database like what
what's it going to match so you have to
use Tesla or Ford or GM those those
terms and you have to like you know one
thing I because you know I'm not from
the finance sector so I don't know
whether earnings is the right word maybe
there's another word like in these 10K
documents maybe you have to say profits
and and so there's also this little bit
like oh if I if I ask what did Ford make
let's try that let's try
this cars yeah well no that you think
but I did this the other earlier and
what did Ford make might give you an
answer with their earnings versus the
word earn because it's depending on what
SIM similarity matches
um okay you're right the manufactur
vehicles but earlier I phrased it in a
particular way and I said how much did
no I said did Ford make more than GM so
let's try that more cars yeah well let's
see
and the thing which drives most software
developers and
scientists about this is the fact that a
lot of these models are not
deterministic so you can run the same
thing again and again and get different
answers um and so but one of the reasons
we built this tool is our clients were
trying to work out how much they could
trust these models and they're TR which
VOR database use which embedding model
how much can we trust it if we're asking
a question about you know what were our
earnings you know and it made stuff up
and our analysts use that to do
something now we're in trouble so it's
very nice that you can have this kind of
generative ask an English language
question and get a good answer well a
good sounding answer but the question is
can you get a good
answer
com yeah I don't know why this is
talking about ragnet now it's like it is
off the rails so anyway um and and now
the thing is one of the reasons one of
the things we had is we started off with
Lang chain and llama index and a lot of
these tools and those tools are really
great to get your feet wet initially
they're what I'd call Enthusiast tools
Lang chain has by now I don't know like
160 different Integrations to pretty
much everything you can think of but
that came at a cost it's it's what I
call an Enthusiast frame Mark we started
there we started using it and then you
start trying to move things into
production you realize you're like oh I
want to set the context window to 250 oh
no I want to change it to 500 why is it
not changing look in the code look in
the code oh someone hot coded it as 250
way down in the code base because they
were trying to make a demo quickly so
there's a lot of and I'm not dissing
them they they are very good tools if
you're trying to get an initial idea of
how things work what we built ragna to
do is to be a place where you can do
research on reinforcement augmented
generation but at the same time part of
the research has to be deploying it to
clients I mean deploying it to groups in
your organization so we wanted not just
some python code we can run in a
notebook we also wanted a full-fledged
python API a rest API and a way to
easily build front-end applications or
Integrations into slack or integ
Integrations into something else and a
low code tool like panel so we can
experiment with something deploy quickly
to a small set of users and since it's
cubed now if we need to go through a lar
lar of set of uses we don't have to
throw the whole thing away we can just
kind of keep moving and so the the real
goal here
is um to be able like for example in
this case I'm taking two models actually
three models gbd4 gbd 3.5 aerob boros
two Vector databases I'm looping through
all of them and asking the same question
how much did GM and Ford earn and oh see
see that's a question I should have used
earn earn not make you know so and then
here if you look you can see chroma with
GPD 3.5 GM earned a net of this and open
Ai gbd4 and this is also still you still
have to look at the sources because I
was doing an experiment earlier and it
very confidently told me that you know
um Ford earned X and then I looked at
the sources all the sources said gm.pdf
so that value Ford earned X came from
its original training set not from the
new data I gave it so one of the
advantages of the this rag approach is
you have some sources so you can kind of
see is it is it making onces up or is it
coming from somewhere
else what people do is when they give it
new give an llm new information they say
please only use this data but guess what
this is an statistical llm it's not a
person your reason with so even if you
telling nlm please only use this data it
may not and some models may be better at
following those instructions than others
so to to really understand and to have
confidence in deploying something you
really need to do your own research for
your organizations with your type of
data and we're proposing that ragma
ragna is a framework you can use for
that fully open source and would love
for people to help us develop it um and
with that oh
and this was cool I told I told canva to
um make a Viking ship on a SE of
documents and I got this and I'm like
that that's actually pretty cool because
if you yeah actually let me go there U
because our the logo we came up for
ragna
actually
yeah so you can visit rag.
chat and that's the logo we came up with
the biking ship with a little document
and so I was like I want a picture for
that and this is what I got out of
canvas generative AI so for playing
around generative air is definitely cool
for asking serious questions about
documents um which you're going to Bas
your business on I think you still need
to do your research and work out how to
put some guard rails on it um with that
I'll take questions
so thank you for the presentation you
said like you can like build chunks and
decide on the chunk size and the chunk
of a lab but if I try them all I would
pay a lot like because I will have to
read until it works so do you have like
just normal rules about how we should do
the chunks and how much they should
that no because it's it depends on I
mean so that's the thing no one has
really
the re we built this tool so you can
start trying to work out what those
rules are I would say because we've come
into this with oh this is a new
technique everyone's talking about it's
really difficult to uh we need the tools
to ask those questions like you know
this chunk size this trunk size um maybe
you do it with a local LM first before
using a thing but you know this this is
a framework to kind of study those
questions and you need to be able to
study those questions programmatically I
want a python script that will Loop
through different chunks sizes and um
with our first iteration when we before
we built this framework our first
iteration we were doing chunking and
some of the simplest ways of some of the
models if you have a PDF it chunk by
Page and that worked okay but then we
had half the data on one page and the
rest of the data because the pages are
arbitrary like stopping points it's not
a great place to chunk so so yeah this
so we don't have a recommended chunk
size you could use this to try and look
it up so yeah one one of the drawbacks
which you mentioned and which a lot of
people find search on the question is
inadequate yeah so people must be
thinking of solutions to that
perhaps L to
interet create better
vors I'm not an expert on that um but
I'm personally not an expert on that but
there's a lot of research going into
different types of similarity searches
and also one of the other things we're
doing which isn't exactly related to
this is taking a question and looking at
the internal databases that are
available and trying to work out which
tables in those databases and trying to
write the SQL or graph query you know
kind kind of yeah that's the kind of
thing I'm talking data catalog yeah yeah
B basically trying to map between you
know the the natural language question
and we we we found this when we worked
because in one of the initial questions
you know the way this whole this project
works is the CEO or CTO says hey I read
this blog I could we use it and and so
one of the questions was you know there
were blogs which showed automatically
like reading an Excel file and giving
you statistics on it and we we we kind
of show that that doesn't work but you
can ask the llm to write you a SQL
statement that you can then use on the
data um and that works really well
because sqls a very limited grammar
same thing if you ask an llm to write
you Panda's code Panda's Epi is massive
and there's like 500 ways to do the same
thing and it's changed over the years
and so the likelihood of getting good
pandas code with the right
capitalization everything is a lot
harder than getting good seq code when
you
asking I wanted to ask if the quality of
responses changes if we also find the
model one of the steps yeah before we
provide it it can and and so the client
with some of the clients we're working
with we're doing both we're we're doing
rag in some cases we're also trying to
find for for the graphql case uh rag
didn't work for graphql um that there's
not that it's it's too we and so with
graphql we're trying to do fine training
because they have some internal graphql
schemas and we're trying to do that but
there we're hitting the issue is the
number of examples you need to do the
fine training is difficult to generate
um especially at the scale of the data
you have available so
yeah uh can I upload my own
cus get answers on uh for the next few
hours but but I will say this retrain it
with your own corus if you like like
they only had um information up to 2021
right but if I I upload this year's
earnings of like 15 companies can I do
comparison well so there's two ways to
do that this is this is one mechanism
this is retrieval aent of generation
with this you're not retraining you're
doing some pre-processing to find
relevant data and then pushing the
relevant data into the prompt what you
want to do is fine-tuning which is take
an existing foundational model give it
new data and say retrain on this data or
like modify your like weights on this
new data and that that is
doable you need gpus and if anyone's
trying to spin up I'm running this on a
T4 right now on the cloud if anyone's
tried to get A1 100s on the cloud you
know how difficult it is to get A1 100s
right now and why Nvidia stock
prices I had another question about
theide
think like
a so in this case we're not doing
anything we're just using converters to
convert PDFs into text one of the things
we talked about is like one of the big
pieces that our framework currently
doesn't do but you know theoretically we
could in a plugin is actually
recognizing tables and figures and we
because right now if you find the table
is just going to read in as a big piece
of text but actually that structured
data that has inherent meaning and
everything else and treating that
differently would make sense so and when
you load load a file and you use ragad
do you have like all the text processing
you know when you skip a line or all the
special characters when you just drag
and drop the PDF like it's completely
messed up when it's red um yeah so so
again ragna is a plugin framework and
it's based on experience we've had with
a couple of clients and so all the
things we've done for clients are not in
the open source version we've we've
done basic plugins like the basic plugin
just just uses P mu PDF to convert the
PDF to text there's nothing else but
since it's a plugin architecture um you
could write your own like pre-processing
algorithm to clean up the data or to
remove new lines or things like that on
the other hand I don't know if you need
remove new lines because theoretically
the vector search kind of just I don't
know I don't know exactly how those
algorithms
work cases where the user query the
concept of taking a chunk and then
retrieving the appropriate chunk for
user query makes makes very good sense
what about in cases where the required
context is the entire document itself
like summarize this document or write
another in a similar
format yeah then then well that's that's
the thing that's where you have to
you're kind of stuck like uh you could
do fine tuning but then if you doine
tuning you're not tuning it on that one
document you're tuning it on a corpus of
documents um the the only other way is
to try one of the models which has like
um like U I think Claude is claiming 70
70,000 tokens of context
um but it's unclear how well those work
and and that's one of the fundamental
things because when we started working
with some of our clients they're like
hey can I just upload my they gave us a
Excel file with I'm trying to remember
10K rows which is not that big of an EXL
file say hey can we can we put this in
and summarize it and we show we we put
700 rows in and showed that we're using
um to get 10,000 rows in we would have
to have 400 gig of GPU Ram which is
impossible you know the amount of ram
that's the problem that's why all these
models have such small Windows is uh
especially if you think of numbers like
in an Excel file every single decimal is
going to be a different data point and
and so it just blows up the memory when
you put it in Vector space
so anthropic claims
of no but here's the
thing yes it can because like I I did
this yesterday and I asked a question
about Ford's earnings and I gave it a
2022 document the answer I got back was
2023 data or 2029 2019 data I know it
got that from the public internet not
from my doct so if they put the catsby
in and asked a question it could have
downloaded it could be using a Wikipedia
summary and giving that back to you I
mean you don't know where about the data
and there's no way to constraint and say
it has to only come from this
PDF in your experience with clients was
fine tuning an effective way to
introduce new facts or information
without impacting the general capability
or was rag a better way
from our initial
experimentation because everything this
is Fast and Furious right because
Something New by by a time you explained
to a client how something worked there
were three new blog posts changing the
way how everything worked so we were
kind of going very very fast with this
um we were wanting to do fine tuning
earlier but uh first of all you couldn't
get gpus and then training data and all
that and so we ended up uh identifying
rag fairly early on and we got pretty
good results with rag one of the biggest
issues we had with the client with one
of the clients is we had some prototype
R applications that were working pretty
well and giving good answers uh and they
were using open air in the back end and
then open air started changing its
algorithm and you know and
then a prompt that was giving a good
answer stopped giving a good answer and
because it's a black
box you have no idea why it's giving a
different answer um and and that's when
they you know and and so now with that
particular kind now we're doing a lot of
fine tuning uh not for the rag Cas not
for the document case more because one
of the ideas is we have all these
internal SQL and graphql system for lots
of things is there a way to take an
unless question I want to know XY Z and
map it to a query for these tables and
you know
um in because right now that process if
if a particular analyst has a certain
question they have to get time with one
of their Specialists who knows all the
databases and two three weeks to write a
custom graph to a query and so that's
the big thing now can we kind of get the
LM to write our queries and see the
we're doing fine tuning for that and and
with the fine tuning the issue is they
have like five or six queries as for as
a train and you need way more than you
find
oh yeah so that happened when we first
started with the clients they all said
oh we want to run local LMS we don't
want to use anything in the cloud and
soon it became fairly clear that getting
gpus is hard getting gpus is expensive
and then they all said oh we can get
open air through Microsoft and Microsoft
gar privacy and then they just went the
hour to arrive
um and more recently opening is also
promising privacy you can you can sign
legal documents and so they were kind of
like okay now we're fine
with evaluation
bu
Beyond
upload
dat not not yet but because it's all
just type an API you could write your
own and and evaluate and we've got some
some many notebooks we've written where
we've just kind of used a similarity to
An Answer we've handwritten and stuff
like that there's also some other things
some of librar that can do that could be
integrated thank you
everyone